hi my name is jonas i am eight years old
and today i have two chefs competing to
make my dream dish
[Music]
hey jonas hello i'm alexis and i'm betsy
nice to meet you we heard you really
like robots yeah i love robots and that
you like to build robots
and so what do you think your robot
would eat
bolts nuts and oil i've done this
several times before and at this point i
don't really take what they say they
want as what they actually want it seems
like you know a lot about tools yep i
know a lot i have a feeling you know a
lot more than me i think so that's
probably true jonas built a robot and
he's eight and i
don't know anything about robots so
jonas has definitely accomplished more
things in life than i have yet okay so
besides like nuts and bolts
and motor oil what else would a robot
eat
wires to get the electricity so the nuts
and bolts seemed pretty simple but when
you started drawing the wires i was like
this is starting to veer off a little
bit i may have maybe missed it but what
is this thing that's the bowl this is
the bowl oh it's a bo oh amazing okay so
that's super helpful and he has to
solder them together
to get electrocuted solder is a pretty
big word for eight when i was eight i
think i was playing outside and playing
with my dolls would he eat something
like this with a spoon he would use his
bare hands and be like oh
good to know what types of foods do you
like to eat i love eating a burrito and
i love meeting exit mexican food do you
like sweet food i love candy i love cake
i love anything sweet how high are your
expectations
not that high i mean
it's pretty high probably pretty high
cool this is going to be a lot harder
than i thought
high five
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
here's my plan for the bowl i'm gonna
create a tortilla bowl so it's actually
gonna be edible then i'm gonna add in
some ground beef some rice and some
refried beans then i'm going to add some
avocado some cilantro and a little bit
of lime for the nuts i'm actually going
to create a nut shape out of a tomato
slice for the bolt i'm going to use a
one inch round of corn and poke it with
the skewer for the wires i'm going to
spiralize a cucumber to create a
wire-like effect and for the motor oil
i'm going to create a basic queso which
he can pour over the entire dish there
was a lot there's a lot going on in my
dish yeah
so here's my plan so for the motor oil
i'm going to make a hard caramel and dye
it black so it'll go all over the plate
for the nuts and bolts i'm going to make
a really simple cookie maybe put some
jolly ranchers in it so it can get like
this mirrored look for the wires i'm
going to have red and blue jolly
ranchers melted that i can stick in the
caramel and then i'll also do some
caramel thread so it'll be like a pile
of wires
oh i did i did print out a wrench is
that that's why i wasn't in his drawing
though yeah but i'm just i just like
want to take it there maybe maybe it'll
just go the extra mile i understand i
understand i definitely consider myself
as like a kid at heart betsy's maybe one
of the loveliest people i've ever met
and she's really good with kids i think
in a way that is much more developed
than what i i know i'm gonna make a
tortilla bowl
similar to his drawing here i'm going to
use a mixing bowl flip it over and place
the tortilla on top then i'm going to
top the tortilla with the same size
mixing bowl we're going to put that in
the oven at 400 degrees for 15 minutes
have you made a burrito bowl before nope
nope
i appeared to be very confident but on
the inside i'm definitely very nervous i
am literally already sweating so much oh
my gosh anyone who knows me
knows that i can get a little
competitive you know i'm here to win now
i'm going to make the filling i'm going
to saute some onions and garlic first
until the onions become translucent and
the garlic becomes fragrant then i'm
going to add in a pound of ground beef
and some taco seasoning betsy's playing
into jonas's love of mexican food which
i think is really smart but i think it'd
be pretty rare for a kid to choose
something savory over sweet so for my
cookies i've got softened butter and
some sugar and i'm just going to combine
those and just get it into a really
smooth consistency next i'm going to add
the egg
again combine it and then i'm just gonna
sift in a few cups of flour sifting the
flour is gonna help eliminate any lumps
and get a really smooth batter i'm gonna
pop this in the refrigerator today i'm
gonna make a robot out of a piece of
paper i think i'm gonna name him bob
[Music]
this is bob but he's made out of paper
that's why his name is paper bob you
wouldn't want to watch me wow
did you hear that
i'm going to move on to the bolts now
i'm going to season a few ears of corn
i'm going to cut these into one-inch
rounds as the head of the bowl
yeah
i have a ridged cast iron to kind of
give some of that grilled charred effect
on the corn i'm gonna brush each round
with some herb butter just some butter
garlic salt pepper and some chopped
cilantro so i'm gonna separate these
jolly ranchers into blue and red because
he was talking about the blue and the
red wires so i'm gonna melt the jolly
ranchers and then whisk them into you
know
like
threads
strings fire what did he want this this
is what i'm doing now that it's melted i
can just drizzle it back and forth over
a greased parchment paper sheet and
they're going to harden really fast and
i can peel them right off stick it in
the caramel oh wow it looks cool it's
like a little weird but it smells weird
but it looks really cool smells really
weird too i have a few of these round
cookie cutters and i think i can just
make them into hexagons to represent the
nuts how many sides is a hexagon six
wait this doesn't this is not right
one
two oh that's an octagon now that's an
octagon so be careful okay so one two
and then three four five six i do wanna
beat alexis but i also love alexis and
like want to help her so it's not a stop
sign so like not a stop sign so clearly
trying to cut out the shape just by
memory is not going well but i think i
have an idea i'm gonna draw it out and
make myself a stencil
yeah that's great that looks good that
looks so good okay making the stencil
total game changer look at this cute
little wrench
do you want something for this dough oh
yes
absolutely or as much as i get it
yes great
i have eaten raw dough like my whole
life and nothing has happened
to me same i wouldn't but
don't do this
so now that my cookie shapes are
finished i'm going to place a jolly
rancher in the middle of the nuts so
that when it melts it looks like this
cool stained glass kind of thing i'm
going to bake them at 350 degrees for 10
to 12 minutes that's it check these out
oh
they look great
isn't that cool i love it i love it
brown or white what are you thinking i
think white i'm just gonna take a cup of
rice and a cup of water mix those
together real quick and throw it in the
microwave for six minutes it's the easy
way out
another part of the filling is the
refried beans i'm making this super
simple just taking some from a can we're
gonna heat that up in a saucepan and
then maybe add a teaspoon of water to
ensure that the beans don't dry out
going into this i really thought that i
was gonna lean more towards the sweet
side i tend to be a lot more confident
when it comes to like making desserts
that's so funny i feel much more
confident with savory foods and sweet
food i'm like
now for my favorite part the motor oil
which is queso wow i have a lot of
things going on
it's going to be a very basic queso
three ingredients american cheese milk
about a half a cup
and just for some added flavor i'm gonna
add in a little bit of taco seasoning i
gotta make sure it's good
[Music]
that's good
moving on to my motor oil i'm going to
add sugar and water to a pan and bring
it to a boil over high heat caramel's
hard caramel is hard and i put a little
bit of corn syrup in here too corn syrup
is an inverted sugar so it doesn't
crystallize now that my motor oil or
caramel is at a dark amber color i'm
just going to add a few drops of food
coloring to make it black but i've never
dyed caramel so
oh oh my god oh wait
this is black but that's what you want i
know
it just looks so crazy
so for my wires
i'm using a spiralizer amazing
oh
i want them to be thinner but i can't
move this
all right i'm just going to oh i own it
okay they're like more like ribbons
ribbon wires
like a pile of wires makes me kind of
want to like
he's gonna be like what is that if this
like is the reason why i don't win then
i'm gonna be so upset like can i just
pour it straight on here
wow that looks cool
oh no my caramel's melting into the
other camel bad idea abort abort mission
abort okay this is not the plan the
jolly ranchers are melting into the
caramel i should have waited a few more
minutes but then maybe it would have
hardened
i kind of wanted to do like caramel
threads with this but oh yeah so this is
really hard caramel that's going to
harden really fast but if i take a fork
and pull up some of the caramel i can
actually pull it into a thread i'm just
going to keep doing this so i get this
kind of pile of wires or caramel threads
on top of the cookies i'm going to now
slice a tomato using a serrated knife
into a hexagon shape to hollow out the
center of each nut i'm going to use a
piping tip i hope they don't put tomato
in there because i don't like tomatoes
slimy like a slug he doesn't like tomato
even if i made him a paper tomato he
won't like it oh no oh no what the queso
is so hard
oh no ew no no no no
now my confidence is starting to plummet
we got betsy at least okay the joy is
that we're both having issues
this cookie has melted into the caramel
also oh i'm making so many mistakes i
feel like season one was my season
season two what's happening oh it's
going back to life guys
not always lost
[Music]
i think i should just stop while i'm
ahead we both have very different are
these the most different dishes we've
had in the history of i draw you cook
i'm really excited to see jonas's
reaction me too um let's bring him to
him and see what he thinks all right
i
really surprise myself i am really proud
with the dish that i'm about to deliver
to jonas so my dish might not look
exactly like the drawing but it has all
the elements i even have cheese motor
oil and what's better than that at the
end of the day i think i did a pretty
good job this isn't exactly how i
envisioned this dish in my head to begin
with but i actually love it i think it
looks so weird and cool the motor oil
looks great the wires are so cool and
he's got all the tools there the same
glass cookies look amazing i want to eat
them myself it totally matches the
drawing
please like it
[Music]
let's eat
i think this is mexican food i don't
know what this was this
this dough
it looks cool i don't care
it's going very slowly
i was getting a little nervous when he
finally like discovered the queso it
obviously doesn't look exactly like
motor oil but it seemed like he was
really having fun like interacting with
the dish
it's good
what's it taste like
corn
this tastes like a lime a little bit
worse than a lemon
i love it it's the best thing
something in that bowl ever know you
haven't tried yet
[Music]
tomato
wait did he just spit something out oh
my god it's the tomatoes honestly when i
was eight i didn't like tomatoes either
i like the corn i like the meat
i like the things
i like everything jonas may not have
like the tomatoes but i'm still feeling
pretty confident if that's the only
thing he really didn't like i can't
really see the tomatoes being like a
deal breaker
this is amazing
this is probably the motor oil i think
these are the bolts and the nuts
right here
is it detailed i feel like jonas's
enthusiasm is boating very well for me
is this a noodle like a raw noodle i
don't know is this a tea
apparently i need to step my bolt cookie
game up
this is amazing
this is one of the goodest cookies i've
ever tasted in my life
this is cool
it's like a raspberry blue raspberry
heaven and i think this is just sugarly
is that my tooth
oh no that's fine
this is too hard for me to cut out it is
edible
[Music]
my confidence is going up he keeps
saying how much he likes it he's saying
it's amazing it's delicious
let's see
hey jonas hello jonas are you stuffed
yes which was your favorite
the mexican dish or the cookie dish
the cookie dish
that's mine
that was amazing
chef alexis here's my dad oh my god
jonas thank you so much
ah here we are again honestly it's good
to be back i'm really disappointed but
obviously i'm so happy for alexis as a
famous robot once said i'll be back
[Music]
you